[Music]
you can't afford to not be good at this
you're dependent on your job as a leader
to get other people to take actions you
need to be skilled in relationships in
influence and communication there's no
getting around it so it gets labeled as
soft skills but it's really a hard
business driver and there's hard science
underneath it that we understand how it
works
so it's not just soft it's a critical
piece of being an effective communicator
people talk about executive presence or
having a presence and most people think
it's something that you're born with or
that person just has it turns out it's
just a set of behaviors that presence is
something that you do there's a set of
behaviors that I like that capsulate
down to about five points on either side
of that equation on the authoritative
side there is slowness in how you move
and how you speak stillness just being
very still like right now I'm not moving
my head very much at all that's a choice
normally I have a little bit more motion
in me so stillness silence is very
powerful and if you can be comfortable
in silence then you can use that to be
more authoritative symmetry has to do
with do i slant a little or just my head
go off to the side I would say this is a
little less authoritative than what this
is and then space what space do you own
and can I reach out and touch someone's
shoulder or shake their hand and make
that first move to invade their space
those are all on the authoritative side
[Music]
so on the other side with approachable
there are 5x and that is filling space
if you can't let assignments happen
that's more approachable if you speak or
move fast
you're usually trying to get all your
words in before you get interrupted
that's not a place of power you know
that you don't have the control just
talk so you try to get everything in all
in one space the next one is folded and
that's where you're folding your body
like crossing your arms crossing your
legs is all the way of sort of
protecting yourself and closing in it's
a little more approachable and even just
that sort of twisting on one foot or
crossing one leg over the other is a
little closer together and it's related
to fidgeting so if you do that and the
motion keeps happening let's also get
very close to what flirting is and
there's a lot of little gestures and
motions that we do that are flirting
including making and breaking eye
contact is more flirtatious and the last
one is about giving space you allow
people into your space you invite people
to take your space so those are all of
the characteristics of being on the
approachable side the first thing is
awareness and you have that if you're
asking the question and the second thing
is to just look at yourself just start
to observe how do I act in different
situations and how do other people act
often I've talked to students and they
want some coaching because they're ready
for a promotion they want to move up
into that partner position or into the
next level and I always tell them to
observe and report on how do those
people act behave verbally non-verbally
because you need to act in that same way
and what got you to where you are isn't
what will get you to the next stage but
you have a perfect opportunity to just
observe so that's the first place in the
second place is to try and make some
change any change and practice it
[Music]
improvisational acting or any acting
class from Community Theatre to a
professional school hones and works on
these tools they're also really fun to
do it's a fun place to play and many
people are afraid of going to do it and
those classes are some of the safest
place in the world because to do that
work you have to create a really safe
space for people to take some risks and
try to show up in different ways than
they normally are so there people are
very skilled and the groups that are
there are very supportive so in most
cases people come in a little afraid and
leave just it elated because it's so
much fun it starts with the fact that
acting is not pretending most people
think it is and if you see actors that
are not great in film and TV they are
the ones that are pretending acting is
about finding a truthful place so when
you see a really good actor you're
seeing how would that person actually
show up in that setting so if it's a
dangerous setting and scary things are
happening you're seeing that person
reacting in the way they show up as a
scared person and when we see that it's
really believable because it's authentic
authentic means in tune with the
emotional state that you're actually in
and not something separate so an example
of that would be I try to put on Mad for
you I think this doesn't really look mad
right it looks kind of cartoonish it's
it's like when you ask a small child to
show me your mad face it's not really
mad it's a mask that they're putting on
when you're really authentically mad you
show up in a way that it's
you're communicating that emotion that's
what authentic is everyone can be
authentically authoritative or
authentically approachable anywhere
along this range they will do it
slightly differently my authentic
authority my authentic powerful is
different than yours which is different
than everyone else that is out there but
it's truthful and if it's truthful then
we believe it and it's really part of
you so acting is not about putting on
the mask or the costume of the character
it's about finding the truthful place
and bringing that out before you walk
into the room you can put on these
gestures in these poses you can do it by
yourself you can go to the restroom and
do it you can do it in the elevator on
the way up or around the corner
expanding your body saying your speech
or a few lines to yourself using the
slow and low tones and because that's
how you want to show up and by doing
that preparation it changes you inside
and it will carry over into the meeting
and that sets you up for success you can
start that before you leave the house so
I have a couple of playlists that are
like ultimate epic movie soundtracks
that are the important themes from
superhero movies and I start listening
to that and I know what's going on I
know I am tricking myself and it still
works every time and I laugh at myself
noticing that it's working and then I
really feel the emotions and so today I
had a lecture before I came in on the
car I was listening to that music and
behind the scenes backstage before I
stepped out onto the stage I had the
music on and I raised my arms I'm in the
back of the greenroom nobody's around
and even if they are I don't care but
using all those techniques to get my
body ready to think about how good it's
going to go and then I walk onstage very
confident full of the way I want to show
[Music]
once you know if you're aware enough to
notice it's going on in you you are
aware enough to then make a change and
if it's going poorly almost any change
you make will make it better if you
notice that you're babbling a little and
you're going on too much you're talking
too fast well as soon as you do stop and
take a pause take a breath get a drink
of water even say just a second I want
to check my notes on this before I
continue and make them wait and it gives
you a chance to breathe and to stop and
to reset so you can do that at any point
from boardrooms to audiences in theaters
they all are the same there's a piece of
them that will allow for you to be a
human being and just show up in that way
and even in that aggressive negotiation
meeting with someone they'll allow for
you to show up and stop and pause and
recover it will not stop the meeting it
feels that way sometimes but I think you
can always stop and reset if I just
start smiling a little more you're going
to start smiling and we're going to
start mirroring back and forth and if I
stop doing it it will pull you a little
that way you can watch in any room the
wave of crossed legs and uncross legs
happen as we all get in sync in
resonance so we are always at reacting
to each other and the reality is we're
all improvising our days that's why it's
also a really useful tool because nobody
gets up and gets a script
well actors do but nobody gives a script
for their day we are all making it up
all the time we are all reacting to
everything that's going on I think what
we're talking about in the work that I
do is being more aware of it being more
comfortable to make more choices reading
the room
and making choices about how we want to
react when it's important when it's
meaningful when we want to do it in
surface of others
[Music]